des salles de classe il ne reste plus
que quelques trous sur le sol et des
manteaux qui ne retrouveront jamais
leurs propriétaires une situation qui a
mobilisé les élus locaux quand on
s'attaque aux écoles c'est avec une
volonté très nette très claire très
cynique de s'attaquer à la République
dans les quartiers et d'empêcher les
jeunes des quartiers d'avoir un espoir
la présidente du Conseil régional
d'Île-de-France s'est rendu sur la
commune pour annoncer la mise à
disposition d'une erpd école régionale
du 1er degré elle accueillera les élèves
dès la rentrée prochaine ils sont 170 à
être concernés ils étaient scolarisés à
l'école élémentaire du bois de l'étang
et l'école maternelle cible d'incendie
volontaires jeudi 29 juin nous allons
réaliser tous les travaux d'accueil je
tenais à le dire maintenant avant que
les parents ne partent en vacances parce
que j'ai vu des parents pleurent parce
que j'ai vu des enfants qui étaient très
inquiets j'ai l'impression qu'on se doit
de répondre à une demande qui urgente et
puis il y a notre mission de service
public et donc il y avait pas solutions
exposée là derrière est une commune qui
a besoin de continuer à je dirais à ce
que leurs élèves poursuivent une
scolarité dans les meilleures conditions
le RPD pouvait répondre à cette demande
donc il y avait pas de sujets la région
Île-de-France votre a mercredi une aide
d'urgence de 20 millions d'euros pour
aider les maires à reconstruire les
équipements publics le Conseil
départemental des Yvelines apportera
aussi une aide financière on a décidé
dès maintenant d'un fond d'urgence qui
sera fait au cas par cas pour les
communes pour les aider à reconstruire
les bâtiments dégradés aujourd'hui on
sait très bien que des communes des
petites communes n'ont pas les moyens de
reconstruire ces équipements les élèves
devraient être accueillis à l'ERPD pour
un minimum de deux ans de quoi laisser
aux écoles le temps d'être reconstruite